well factory I was in MC Hammer music
video were you really yep
is it true not me not looking for the
video believable that everybody's about
to lose it I mean I'm in it for loot
umbrella I'm in it for a hot second
which one I'm not in the back dancing I
thought I'd be in it dancing but clearly
not oh dude you're a hot SEC what no
song with uh yeah you definitely [ __ ]
remember how are you thinking about it
dude well don't know which MC car you
run CH of videos dude what I think it's
gonna run run run MC Hammer run oh my
god dude you couldn't get any [ __ ]
weirder bruh were you an MC Hammer video
Oh bro you met him in a bathroom stall
I was it because I'm you met him and
Paul wall in a bathroom stall listen
water I got questions bro I get some
questions okay well you don't have any
answers you know these people in the
stalls you got questions better run
that's me that's their jay-z dis video
dude I mean this is so stupid I'm in for
like a second of video not like dancin
yeah I'm a video vixen who cares bro
it's obvious you [ __ ] had the weirdest
career of anyone ever we've ever met
what are you in next almost odd how much
we're gonna kick Brendon then you
chasing a couple black guys in the woods
this looks illegal
you're not giving out a show D okay yeah
why are you right there
oh that's Kat will you write that's MC
Hammer that's me in the back my gun will
you stop so we can all feel what it's
like to realize you were in this video
what do you think what are you stepping
on it bro let's go to the culture corner
man I don't know how to feel right now
dude this is crazy
and what do you mean by crazy I would
like to know a little bit more about
this like cool factor
you've done enough we've seen the video
there's you behind Kat
it's it really yes well this is when he
was smoking Katt Williams at the time
because he is very Katt Williams in this
picture all right Derrick 1qy interview
your your buddy here I think this is the
blackest [ __ ] you've ever done give it
our bug don't yeah thanks man I don't
know how to feel about this
I have conflicting feelings thank you it
makes sense I mean I have no words
thank you thank you
oh I'm sorry who was a big hammer video
nobody all right yeah I was in a bad
baby music video you frequent piece of
yeah that's right you played a pedophile
bro listen no I made a curious adult you
paid you played a pedophile listen bad
baby ain't [ __ ] MC him she's the MC
Hammer of today you goon no dance and
see everybody get famous off [ __ ] dr.
Phil catch me outside
MC Hammer you [ __ ] bro great dude you're
the one who's standing behind him like
you're trying to sell them at an auction
bro this is the saddest piece of
videography I've ever seen dude oh you
not condone this kind of [ __ ] I want to
say that but you do that bad baby video
where you're a pedophile the curious
adult Brendon okay who was misled by the
[ __ ] hey my society hey let's do this
have the fans vote what's cooler MC
Hammer video or a bad Barbie or what the
[ __ ] that up cat there's a great how
take that has never been released of
their like say whatever you want too bad
baby right now right we're gonna do this
and I was like there's you crazy [ __ ] I
love it I love it I just think it's too
like it's too spot-on
oh yeah that's right he just needs to on
the nose they don't
they're like hey bro no you tell us the
way well we can't use that deal we
definitely why because yeah broccolini
get your life together
I'm not touching